finally permission granted for alexei
navalny to be flown to berlin for
emergency treatment
but not without a fight
doctors in omsk siberia claiming all day
that his condition was too unstable to
travel
his wife julia writing to the russian
president asking him to intervene
but the air ambulance stayed waiting on
the tarmac as navalny lay in a coma in
hospital
heavily guarded and fighting for his
life
we think that the transfer was refused
to give time to allow the chemical
substance and alex's body to disappear
he obviously isn't in good condition of
course we can't trust this hospital
doctors in omps declaring after hours
spent huddled with investigators that
they did not think he'd been poisoned
we've come to the conclusion that
judging by the fact there were no
poisons found in his blood
or other biological materials he has a
metabolic disorder
lowering of blood sugar levels to be
specific due to a rapid change of
pressure
everyone thinks it was during takeoff
these were navalny's groans shortly
after takeoff yesterday just before he
lost
consciousness not the kind of violent
deterioration generally associated with
low blood sugar levels
and very few in russia or elsewhere by
the line that this wasn't poison
written on these cups at a demonstration
in st petersburg
the simple question who would drink tea
in russia
in 2020 navalny has walked the gauntlet
for years as the kremlin's toughest
critic and scourge of the pervasive
corruption by which the russian system
operates
with so many enemies the question is who
did this
this is a an inevitable side effect of
the way that russia is run
it is not this extraordinarily
disciplined lockstep
dictatorship but a rather kind of
chaotic and ramshackle system
in which putin essentially tends to set
out broad
expectations and his various
courtiers and wannabe courtiers
struggle to do what they think will
please the boss and often they get it
wrong
the situation at the oms hospital was
nothing short of chaotic
german medical care at least offers
higher chances of survival
but these are anxious times for
navalny's family his team
and for all who care for the notion of
political freedoms in russia
dynamagne sky news